the Joe Rogan experience um what else
was a bummer well you want to talk about
the bonus I found that to be entirely
hilarious ruthlessly unscientific yeah
and like the whole thing with the guy
saying you know I'm gonna eat what a
gorilla eats I mean they're showing this
guy who's protecting rhinos who are
being slaughtered for their for their
horns like what does that have anything
to do with eating meat yeah they're
they're morally equated that with eating
exactly murder well then what they're
doing is pretty obvious what they
weren't doing that yes even though they
didn't say that that's what they were
doing they're attaching themselves to an
indisputable cause yeah
you know I mean everybody wants people
to stop shooting rhinos for their horns
everyone does if you don't you're an
[ __ ] don't eat meat what knock that
in there what the [ __ ] did you do yeah
yes so the for those who haven't seen
the film that the the erection that the
boner experiment if we're gonna call it
that if they it was Aaron Spitz who the
urologist and he puts penis rings on a
bunch of NFL players and then he looks
at measures the effects of different
meals on their erections both the the
circumference I guess the size of the
erection the duration and the intensity
of the erections so he feeds the players
burritos with meat in them and then he
feeds them the same burrito with like a
plant protein I'm not sure what it was
tempeh or something like that and then
he claims beans was the beans okay yeah
maybe
and then he claims it that Fleitz who
ate the pure plant burritos had 500%
more frequent erections and also
increased strength of erections so hmm
what can we conclude from this
experiment absolutely nothing because it
was just an experiment that was made up
and done in a film it was not peer
reviewed there was no it's not
scientific at all you know that's the
whole scientific well he could have been
scientific right if they did it in
different orders so they put the the the
penis band on the dudes one night they
had
whatever the [ __ ] they had I mean you
know a thing with steak burritos and
then the next night they put the penis
bands on them again and they have a meat
beans and so they say you got more
erections
did you guys jerk off in between them
did you guys have sex did you get used
to having the penis band on when you
slept with it the first time did it
bother you did it interrupt your sleep
the second time were you more
comfortable with it did you guys try to
reverse it one day the first day on a
different group of people give them the
band and make them eat a vegetarian diet
then the next day give them the band on
the second day and make them eat steak
did you did you switch that up you can
ask any number of questions and that's
the whole point is that's why we have
science that's why we have a process of
peer review that's why we have
reproducibility meaning even if one
group comes up with one finding it's not
really worth much until somebody else
reproduces that something like 90 90
percent or more of findings scientific
findings are not reproduced that's that
means that we can't trust them so I
would like to know if they were asked to
not engage in sexual intercourse or
masturbation during that time period
because that would that would make sense
that they were getting more erections
and more fuller erections the next day
especially the young guys that are you
know savages well I went to them playing
football I went to look at research like
is there any peer-reviewed research that
shows that plant-based diets are better
for erectile function and lower the risk
of erectile dysfunction couldn't find
anything I did find studies one study of
a Mediterranean diet which includes
animal some animal products reduced
erectile disfunction relative to a
low-fat diet which maybe might have
fewer animal products that kind of
contradicts it perhaps there were
studies that showed that like diet
quality is more is important so Western
diet and high in processed foods led to
erectile dysfunction
diet rich in flavonoids containing foods
which be pets foots and vegetables
reduced erectile disfunction but none of
that says it has anything to do with
meat just says like don't eat a junk
food diet
we don't want an erectile dysfunction
yeah it's just deceptive oh there was
another but you know it does show that
those guys did get more hard-ons
under that circumstance but as you said
what does that mean
what does it mean and and can we even
trust it I mean frankly given some of
the other stuff in the film right can
you trust it and you trust right I mean
who's to say right
[Applause]